une Marseillaise pour commencer une
nouvelle soirée historique pour le
football français plusieurs dizaines de
supporters des Bleus ont décidé de
donner de la voie au forum Armand
Peugeot de Poissy lors de ce quart de
finale contre l'Angleterre puis soudain
à la 17e minute de jeu Aurélien
ivre de bonheur les pissé
1-0 ce sera le score à la pose on a
maîtrisé le ballon bon les Anglais ont
été un peu dangereux mais on a réussi à
marquer tôt donc on aurait plutôt pas
mal pour la deuxième mi-temps là du coup
d'engagement après ce qui compte c'est
de travailler en équipe et je crois
qu'on a su mettre l'intensité qu'il
fallait dans les duels pour pouvoir se
projeter vers l'avant et marquer le but
qu'il nous faut pour la victoire
refroidi par légalisation anglaise en
début de seconde période les supporters
français continuent d'y croire et la
libération arrivera la 78e minute grâce
à un but de Giroud après quelques
frayeurs les Français sont en
demi-finales de la 22e Coupe du Monde
soulagée et c'est mérité des soldats on
a été combattifs si ce méritait quand
même très content c'était compliqué mais
on l'a fait c'était compliqué mais c'est
ce qui rend la Coupe du Monde
intéressante à regarder mais finalement
ça finit bien Harry Kane il a pas
l'habitude de louper des peaux il a
loupé le peno c'est parfait quelques
heures plus tôt ce sont les supporters
marocains qui ont exulté dans ce bar
portugais situé près de la mairie de
Trappes
au Maroc s'impose face au Portugal sur
le score de 1 à 0 direction les
demi-finales une première pour un Club
Africain
on va partir on va
après une nuit avec des scènes de liesse
aux quatre coins du département
supporter français et marocain se
retrouveront ce mercredi 14 décembre à
20h pour cette demi-finale déjà
historique que le meilleur gagne